the daily wire has the update the
washington dc medical examiner said that
it will not be performing autopsies on
bodies of aborted babies that were
turned into police last week probably
pro-life activists and medical
professionals say that the bodies show
signs of illegal and gruesome abortion
procedures and these activists fear the
bodies will be incinerated before proper
autopsies can be
conducted live action's director of
government affairs told the daily wire
on monday
one of the worst injustices would be if
the medical examiner and dc government
dispose or incinerate the bodies of
these children before a full autopsy can
be completed
he said quote the abortionists do not
want autopsies performed because they
may indicate violations of federal law
dc must preserve these remains until a
full fair and thorough investigation can
can be completed now to remind you about
the story this is um
a
pro-life group i forget the name of it
the progress the progressive
anti-abortion uprising group um one of
the members of that group obtained
the bodies of
five children who are victims of
abortion
and obtained these bodies from a
whistleblower apparently within the
clinic
and according to that whistleblower
these babies were killed in illegal
procedures whether it's partial birth
abortion which is supposedly illegal or
even there's evidence
that you can plainly see if you see the
pictures um as many people did as as
over the weekend
the kind of pictures that are seared
into your mind forever and you never
forget
but you can plainly see the evidence
that even
potentially
this these were abortions that occurred
after birth
now by the way the distinction between
a partial birth abortion and an after
birth abortion a post-birth abortion are
semantics at best
partial birth abortion the baby is being
killed
as he emerges from the birth canal like
part of his body
is out of the birth canal
and then um his skull is crushed or
you know
something
basically a vacuum is
is
stuck into his skull and his brains are
sucked out of his body i mean that's
that's how these procedures are carried
out that's the reality of it um
so that's partial birth which was legal
in this country for a long time now it's
supposedly illegal and then after birth
abortion or post birth abortion is
infanticide in other words is just wait
for the baby to fully emerge and then
kill it there's there's no
moral distinction at all between the two
um there's no medical distinction or
physical distinction either certainly no
scientific distinction
so there's evidence that this is what
happened to these um babies
the police
once the pro-life group obtained
the bodies of these victims they
contacted the police and said
we come come pick them up
and so far the police are saying we're
not going to investigate
which like we talked about yesterday
whether we're talking about abortion
victims or anything else you're given
the bodies of five dead people
wouldn't you want to do an autopsy to
figure out how they died
isn't that the first thing you would do
well not according to the police anyway
here's executive assistant chief of
police sean benedict
explaining that um
although they were just made aware of
these victims uh they still have just
decided already that everything is fine
and there's really nothing to
investigate listen um in regards to the
house that was found with numerous
fetuses today can you confirm if that is
the home of lauren handys and do you
have any idea on how uh those fetuses
got there and if you all have been
working with other authorities across
the country sure so there's there's a
couple of there's two different things
going on here um miss handy is uh been
indicted on a federal investigation led
by the fbi that mpd was not a part of um
so that's number one the second piece is
that we were led to that uh house that
you mentioned
we did recover items that were
these are preliminary results ocme
looked took a look at those items they
are have been confirmed as fetuses
what we're seeing now is they those
fetuses were aborted in accordance with
dc law so we are not investigating
this incident along those lines does
this be anything criminal in nature
right now about that
except for how they got into this house
and so we'll continue to look at that
are you working with authorities in
other states with how they got here to
the dc area
this is very early on and i think the
fbi's case may touch on interstate but
at this point we're we're about a day
into this i don't know if that doesn't
make your blood boil um
then
you have no soul he's he's
referring to
dead children dead babies as items
he says oh we obtained the items
i ask you would he ever talk about
um
you know the victims of a
car crash or
a mass shooting if there's a mass
shooting at a mall somewhere
and he's talking about recovering the
bodies what he'd say oh yeah well we
obtained 15 items
that's how he's talking about these
children because he does not recognize
the children as being human beings he
doesn't recognize them as people and as
far as he's concerned even though you
have ted you have five children
who have been brutally killed
um
for him the only crime worth
investigating is not how they were
killed
but how they ended up how they were
discovered the crime is in the
discovering of the crime
pretty common theme when it comes to the
abortion industry like we talked about
yesterday it's the same thing the center
for medical progress
when they conducted an undercover
investigation and revealed that planned
parenthood was
chopping up babies and harvesting their
organs and selling them for parts like
an old vehicle or something you know
um and the crime there
was not that this was happening it's
that the center for medical progress
found out about it so they're the
criminals
talk about shooting the messenger almost
in a literal sort of way
um
and he's just decided that we're not
even gonna look into it
all they did
well they haven't done an autopsy
so this was just sort of the naked eye
test they they looked at the bodies and
said no illegal abortion there is no way
to know that they cannot possibly know
it
no it's quite the opposite they fear
they're afraid
that there was something illegal that
happened and that if they do the autopsy
they'll discover it and they will have
to prosecute
a prominent abortionist in the city
which they refuse to do
because the abortion industry is
basically a quasi-governmental agency at
this point these are it is protected by
the government and funded by the
government as if it is the government as
if it's part of the government
and the only the only hazard in this
conversation and we should be calling
this is something i mean all
conservatives i don't care if you're
conservative just if you're a decent
person
you should be demanding that this is at
least investigated there is no reason
why you wouldn't do an autopsy
well you just don't feel like it you got
better things to do you don't have time
the only reason to do it is that you are
blatantly trying to cover up a crime
and every decent person should be
demanding that that doesn't happen
the only hazard in this conversation is
that it obscures the point
that even if these were quote legal
abortions it's still a horrific crime
maybe not according to the law books but
that's because the law books themselves
are
twisted and the law books need to be
changed
so there's a crime at least a horrific
moral crime that occurred one way or
another
but either way there needs to be an
investigation
is uh
i don't know how i'm still shocked by
this kind of thing somehow
just that they could be so out in the
open about it you might as well hold a
press conference and just say to the
press that hey listen we don't
we're not interested in prosecuting
abortionist here that's not what we do
so whatever he did
not we're not looking into you might as
well say that
they have all but said that
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content